i will however confirm that the phased
and gradual return to school
that i said we were hopeful about when i
updated parliament two weeks ago
will go ahead as planned from monday
i'll say more about that and also about
the importance of carefully implementing
and monitoring that change
later in addition i'll give an
assessment of the current state
of the pandemic and i will signal when
and how
we do hope to give an indication of the
criteria
for beginning our exit from lockdown and
the order in which
we will be aiming to do so when the time
is right
firstly though i'll briefly recap on
today's statistics
the total number of positive cases
yesterday was 773 which is six percent
of all tests carried out
and means that the overall number of
cases is now 193
148. 1 383 people are in hospital
which is 45 fewer than yesterday and 100
people had an intensive care which is
two fewer than yesterday
i regret to report that in the past 24
hours though
a further 49 deaths were registered of
patients who first tested positive
over the previous 28 days and the total
number of deaths under
this daily measurement is now 6764
and once again my condolences go to
everyone who has lost a loved one